hello and welcome to the agenda the
summer break over its back to business
for any please let's take a look at
what's happening at the September
plenary we're not quite living in
America but we too have a state of the
union address every year the president
of the Commission Jose Manuel Barroso
comes the plenary to present the e u--'s
priorities for the year ahead and lively
debate follows his dress find out what
bro so has to say first thing on
Wednesday morning after parliament and
the ECB agree to terms the final vote to
adopt the regulation on banking
supervision and the role of the ECB will
play as they use financial watchdog it
takes place on Tuesday afternoon a
debate with the president of ECB Mario
Draghi in the state of negotiations on
the EU banking Union is also scheduled
earlier on in the morning betting bingo
the lottery everything's available
online there are some 7 million online
gamblers in Europe by 2015 the industry
could be worth some 13 billion euros but
the EU wants better regulation to
protect consumers from fraud and ensure
that national law complies with EU
standards mep s boat on the report on
tuesday with less than a year to go the
September plenary will see the launch of
the institutional campaign the 2014
parliamentary elections leading
proceedings we vice presidents Annie
potty matter and autumn are Karis who
will unveil the theme and key event of
the campaign to the media find out more
on Tuesday and that's all we have for
this agenda take care and enjoy the week
oh I better catch my train to Strasbourg